foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie a lot
of you been asking me to do a video
about the Harry Potter reboot trailer
they just dropped in the announcement
about how they're going to plot out this
full reboot series that they're doing
I'll explain what's going on and what it
means for the new Harry Potter movies
that they also talked about JK Rowling
also said they're continuing to do more
Harry Potter movies but set in different
parts of the timeline if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes they only just
started working on it but they're going
full steam ahead and I will do episode
videos when it releases they've been
working on this for a long time trying
to lock JK Rowling down to a deal like
they had to get her to sign on the
dotted line and the important thing is
first this is meant to be a full-on
reboot of the original Harry Potter
books which is a bit of a surprise like
we knew they were doing a Harry Potter
series we were just kind of wondering
what it would actually be about but
they're rebooting the events of Harry
Hermione Ron all the main characters
story that we read during those original
books and they already greenlit the full
series for order which is Way Beyond
what you normally get this means they
ordered Beyond just the first episode
like there's no pilot episode or just a
first season pretty much the entirety of
all the original books have been green
lit to episodes and as part of the deal
that it took to get a Harry Potter
series about the mainline characters
again they had to approve a 10-year Run
for the series meaning at least 10
seasons they didn't say exactly how many
episodes per season but it would be
about what house the dragon Game of
Thrones were meaning 8 to 10 episodes
per season every single fan of the books
and there are millions many millions of
us now asking there aren't 10 books
there are only seven books why are there
10 seasons for seven books this is
because part of JK Rowling's deal with
Warner Brothers and HBO to get the
series actually going to actually sign
the deal was that they would cover every
single thing in all the books without
cutting out any plot which is what
happened with the original Harry Potter
movies it's actually happening with Game
of Thrones and House of the Dragon right
now too to talk about George R Martin
another major author who's getting a lot
of stuff cut out of his books to cram it
into seasons is basically what happened
with the original Harry Potter movies if
you only watch the original movies which
Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson and Rupert
Grint even though they split the events
of the last book into two movies they
did eight movies for seven books they
still wound up cutting a massive amount
of stuff out of each book to cram the
events of each one into a single movie
with the exception of Harry Potter and
the Deathly Hallows and even then with
two full movies in about four and a half
hours to do that one book they still had
to cut out a lot of stuff from Deathly
Hallows so the 10 seasons allows them to
go full Deathly Hallows for all the
books when they need to break the events
of some of the larger books in the
multiple seasons and it also means they
can start working on Season Two Season
three so on much much sooner so that
there aren't massive breaks between the
seasons which is what just happened with
House of the Dragon HBO waited until
like the last possible minute after
House of the Dragon season one had
released and been proven to hit like
everyone loved it so they're like great
we'll do all the seasons now but that
means that they couldn't start working
on season two till way way later and
that's why we had to wait two years for
House of the Dragon season two and they
don't want that to happen with something
like Harry Potter which they know is
going to be crazy popular zoom in
enhance on the book chart here the first
two books are the shortest by far so
they can probably cover the events of
Sorcerer's Stone and Chamber of Secrets
completely in season 1 and season 2
Prisoner of Azkaban is pretty close they
could probably cover that in a single
season three but you notice starting
with Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
the length of each book more than
doubles which is where they need to
start using two seasons to cover the
events of each book they might try to
cram Goblet of Fire into a single season
4 or just give it a slightly longer
episode run but the Order of the Phoenix
would probably be season five and season
six Half Blood Prince would probably be
season seven and season eight and then
obviously Deathly Hallows would be
season 9 and season 10. that could wind
up changing a little like they could
always wind up doing 11 seasons and use
two seasons for goblet of fire but this
is just the beginning they only have a
loose plan for how long they'll spend on
each season like remember we're talking
10 years into the future now a lot it
can change in 10 years the original
actors Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson
Rupert Grint as well as the other actors
have talked about how they feel about
them doing a reboot in the past most of
them like the Daniel Radcliffe and Emma
Watson have said they never plan on
coming back as the characters in new
movies set later in the timeline but
both of them have said oh we do know
they'll eventually reboot the movies
it's just a reality like it doesn't
bother us that much
so yeah it was it was very
[Music]
it was a very good 10 years so they
don't care quite as much about them
actually rebooting their characters
Rupert Grint though was like the one of
the three Mains who was like oh yeah
totally I would love to come back and do
an older version of Ron but it doesn't
really make sense to do that unless you
also get the older Daniel Radcliffe to
do older Harry Potter and Hermione to
come back before all this happened a lot
of us had way Tamer theories about their
Harry Potter series plans most of us had
assumed that they would do a serious set
during a different part of the timeline
like a Marauder series because they
could still feature most of the major
characters from the main series like
Voldemort Dumbledore just as younger
versions of the characters that's kind
of what they did with the Fantastic
Beast movie like they kind of slowly
turned into Dumbledore movies even
though they didn't start out that way a
lot of us also thought that they might
do a Severus Snape series or a young
Voldemort series or they go way back in
the timeline and do a Founder series
about the four founders of Hogwarts
godric Gryffindor Helga Hufflepuff
Rowena Ravenclaw and Salazar Slytherin
one of the important details though is
that JK Rowling will not be writing all
the episodes herself the left actually
have teams of experienced showrunners
and show writers actually working on the
series and she'll just get approval on
scripts which is kind of how the
situation with the original Harry Potter
movie writing went where she didn't do
the bulk of the writing of the movies
herself she just approved a lot of their
scripts when they got to the Fantastic
Beasts movie though they actually did
let her write most of those movies which
is why the movies felt a little bit
weaker because she's amazing at writing
novels like the original Harry Potter
books are amazing books but she's not a
great screenwriter so I'm glad that
they're going back to the old method of
writing the episodes for the series I
think that'll just ultimately lead
towards better quality actual episodes
but according to JK Rowling they are
still making new Harry Potter movies and
all of our theories have now been flip
and now the new movies are going to be
telling stories that are jumping around
in the timeline JK Rowling was kind of
non-committal when asked about which
events the next movies would cover
Warner Brothers already said that they
don't have any more fantastic Beast
movies and development so that franchise
is basically dead with the last
Fantastic Beasts movie and it sounds
like they'll do Marauders movies a
Founder series of movies events like
that or they go full Star Wars and try
to do events much later in the timeline
much longer after the main characters
have passed away house the dragon is
doing this for Game of Thrones right now
but just as HBO series like their only
series they haven't announced Game of
Thrones movies or anything like that
just jumping around in the timeline I
just did another video for that Game of
Thrones a night of the Seven Kingdoms
trailer which they also released when
they released this Harry Potter reboot
trailer like there were a bunch of
different series they all announced at
the same time with trailers they did
just bring back the entire Harry Potter
cast from the movies for a reunion
special on HBO Max a little while ago
but that was more of a glorified behind
the scenes featurette kind of like the
cast of a friend's reunion they didn't
come back to do a new movie or a new
episode they just sat around and talked
about the movies like a longer version
of a Blu-ray DVD special feature because
they just announced the full series of
being green lit it's going to be at
least 20 25 before they can start
getting episodes out they haven't
announced any kind of casting yet who's
going to be playing all the characters
but there could be some of the original
movie actors returning in different
roles because they're obviously much
older now so they'd have to be playing
different characters
he gave an interview
uh on a podcast where you said if you
ever
play another character like Sirius Black
or something how long after the podcast
went live did a producer call you to see
if you were soon if you're a fan of the
DC series they did this with stuff like
The Flash series in modern day where
they had the John Wesley ship from the
90s Flash series comeback as Barry's
father so they could bring back some of
the original actors just playing
slightly different characters but the
thing is obviously it hasn't been that
long that's why a lot of fans got upset
because it's literally like right after
they finished the movies it hasn't been
that long usually when they reboot
movies and Warner Brothers did just
announce that they're rebooting the
original Lord of the Rings movies with
new movies usually they wait more than
20 years before trying to reboot things
like we're not talking about Spider-Man
here at Sony that's the best example of
them rebooting stuff right away with
them rebooting from Tony McGuire into
Andrew Garfield and then very quickly
soon after into the Tom Holland version
of Spider-Man everybody's now hoping for
Harry Potter into the potterverse where
like all the different characters come
and they just say that they all happen
in different universes where like Daniel
Radcliffe comes back with whatever new
version of Harry Potter they wind up
casting the funny thing about that is
that Daniel Radcliffe is like a hardcore
Star Wars fan a lot of these other
franchises so it would be funny to see
him pop up in like a Marvel movie or a
Star Wars movie one of the reasons why
you don't see that happening though Emma
Watson too is because they made so much
money on Harry Potter they're so iconic
as those characters they don't feel like
they need to do movies just for the
paycheck like you would get giant
paychecks for these big comic book
movies or Big Star Wars movies so it
just enables them to be a little more
selective with their roles and just do
weirder stuff because they already have
giant piles of money which is how you
get Daniel Radcliffe playing a farting
corpse and the funny thing about that
movie big coincidence here is that the
directors of that farting corpse Daniel
Radcliffe movie are actually the
directors who made everything everywhere
all at once which was fantastic
everybody let me know in the comments
though like what do you want them to do
for this new 10-year long plus Harry
Potter series who do you want them to
cast for actors is still a little bit
early to start talking about who they're
going to cast but obviously there'll be
much younger versions of the characters
and as for the Lord of the Rings reboot
movies they haven't released any kind of
teaser or trailer for that yet so it
sounds like it's going to be much longer
before those start releasing Elijah Wood
also kind of did the same thing like the
Daniel Radcliffe thing where you're
asked about how you feel about the
reboot like the rebooting the Lord of
the Rings movies what do you think about
this he was actually pretty nice about
it like oh you know I knew they would
reboot them eventually I hope they do a
good job hope this isn't a big cash grab
so with any luck they'll actually spend
the time that they need to to make this
Harry Potter series actually be good
otherwise that next 10 years would be a
slog but like I said because they just
started they're going to be writing
scripts now starting actual work on the
series it'll take them a couple years
before you actually get episodes so
it'll actually be a good long while
before we actually get the next Real
trailer I'll probably wait till we start
getting really big announcements or like
really big trailers before I start doing
some more videos but leave all your
requests in the comments below if you
have any special questions about what's
going on with this Harry Potter reboot
or any of the other big reboots that are
happening I just did a trailer video for
Game of Thrones night of the Seven
Kingdoms so I'll put a link for that at
the end of this and down in the
description below you can click here to
watch that and click here for my
Mandalorian season 3 episode 8 finale
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and I'll see you guys
in the next one